seit dem internationalen astronauten
progress in adelaide überschlagen sich
die nachrichten in sachen mond-mission
erst war nur von einer raumstation die
rede
die um den mond kreisen soll jetzt geht
es schon um die besiedlung und die pläne
für die raumstation scheinen sogar
konkrete zu sein als bisher angenommen
was für den mond geplant ist und wie es
mit einer möglichen besiedlung aussieht
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
jetzt geht es wirklich schlag auf schlag
ein interview der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung mit dem deutschen
astronauten thomas reiter zeigt jetzt
wie konkret die pläne schon sind fast im
verborgenen liefen die vorbereitungen
und es geht schon in zwei jahren los den
nacharbeiten
die fünf an der internationalen
raumstation beteiligten nationen amerika
russland europa japan und kanada bereits
seit drei jahren an dem projekt bereits
seit 2012 entwickelt die esa zwei
service module für das raumschiff orion
mit dem die raumstation deep space
gateway versorgt werden sollen und auch
weitere elemente für die raumstation
selbst sind wohl schon in der
entwicklung 2009 10 soll bereits der
erste flug in eine mondumlaufbahn
stattfinden und bereits 2022 soll mit
dem bau der stationen begonnen werden
das wäre zwei jahre früher als bisher
vermutet es scheint dass das jetzt durch
die zusage russlands möglich geworden
ist die sich bisher noch nicht so
konkret dazu geäußert hatten erst auf
dem astronauten kongress in adelaide
hatte der roskosmos chef igor komarow
auf die beteiligung an der raumstation
verkündet laut reiter ist man jetzt froh
bei dem bau der raumstation auf die
expertise der russen zurückgreifen zu
können insbesondere da die mondstation
statt 400 kilometern 400.000 kilometer
von der erde entfernt ist die
europäische weltraumagentur esa will für
die mondstation übrigens ein ionen
triebwerk mit 20 kilowatt leistung bauen
und ein modul mit kommunikations
terminal treibstofftanks einer
luftschleuse für wissenschaftliche
nutzlasten und einem neuartigen adapter
an den raumschiffe andocken können und
auch eine mondbasis kommt jetzt wieder
laut reiter ins gespräch sie passe
perfekt zu einer raumstation im mond
orbe zitat die vision eines permanent
bewohnten mond dorfes wie sieht der esa
generaldirektor jan wörner vor zwei
jahren publik gemacht hat ist bei
unseren internationalen partnern auf
großes interesse gestoßen
einschließlich russland man könnte vom
deep space gateway aus sowohl die
besiedlung des erdtrabanten vornehmen
als auch zum mars aufbrechen da sind zum
einen sehr spannende perspektiven und
zum anderen soll es jetzt wohl viel
schneller gehen als gedacht ich bin
extrem gespannt wenn es auch sein und
kein video dazu verpassen wollen und
auch zu allen anderen themen da sollten
wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen
ich den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit mond raumstation konkrete pläne
da gibt es weitere details zur
mondstation deep space geld wäre also
nicht verpassen und draufklicken viel
spaß haben und ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran